j'espère que vous avez faim parce que je
vais vous parler d'alimentation et
d'alimentation
d'avenirecte al vous savez je suis comme
vous je m'appelle Clément j'ai 28 ans et
moi ce que j'aime c'est aller au
supermarché avoir le choix manger des
fraises en plein mieu du mois de février
manger de la viande quasiment tous les
jours puis surtout payer le moins cher
possible bon ça c'est céit avant avant
que j'apprenne qu'en 2050 on sera 9
milliards sur terre 9 milliards de
personnes qui va falloir qu'on nourrisse
et pour nourir ces 9 milliards de
personnes faudrait qu'on soit capable de
doubler notre production actuelle
alimentaire or on exploite déjà 70 % des
terres arables des terres
cultivables alors comment est-ce qu'on
fait c'est assez simple on surpêche on
rase la la forêt primaire pour planter
du soja on utilise des des pesticides
des fongicides tout ce qui finit en C et
puis surtout on plante en
monocultureors je vous rassure je suis
pas là pour vous déprimer smile je suis
là pour vous apporter des solutions il
existe des
solutions les par exemple la viande
artificielle les microal les plantes et
puis les insectes alors pourquoi les
insectes c'est simple ça tient en TR
lettres rendement nutrition onement al
rendement c'est c'est très simple les
insectes sont les champions de la
conversion énergétique ils ont besoin de
très peu de nourriture très peu d'eau et
très peu d'espace pour grandir et
s'épanouir également ils se reproduisent
très vite et en grande quantité il faut
à peu près 3 mois pour une génération de
criquet contre plusieurs mois voir
plusieurs années pour les plantes et le
bétail conventionnel ensuite l'insecte
il est à 80% comestible ça vous parle
peut-être pas mais un bœuf 40 %
seulement du bœuf est comestible ça veut
dire du gâi principalement et puis enfin
les insectes sont très résistants ils
sont adaptés à la terre entière c'est 80
% de la biomasse de la somme de tous les
animaux sur terre donc on peut les
élever dans toutes les conditions à peu
près partout ce qui permettrait de
rendre accessible cette source de
protéine à l'ensemble de la planète bon
côté nutrition maintenant c'est assez
simple he les insectes c'est la protéine
la protéine
63 % de protéines dans un grillon versus
55 % pour du bœuf voire même 25 % pour
du poulet en plus c'est des protéines
qui sont complètes on retrouve la somme
de tous les acides aminés essentiels que
votre corps ne peut pas synthétiser
lui-même et qui va devoir puiser dans
son alimentation alors c'est pas tout il
y a aussi des vitamines la fameuse
vitamine B12 qu'on retrouve pas dans le
rigne végétale et puis également des
minéraux le fer par exemple ou des
acides gras polyinsaturés
et puis des fibres donc d'un point de
vue nutritionnel c'est vraiment très
intéressant et j'ajouterai même que le
génome de l'insecte est très éloigné du
génome humain par conséquent ça va
éviter plein de maladies transmissibles
à l'homme notamment la vache folle assez
peu de chance d'avoir un criquet fou un
jour ça risque pas
d'arriver alors après d'un point de vue
environnemental c'est ce qui nous
intéresse le plus dans notre entreprise
est-ce que vous avez une petite idée de
combien il faut de litres d'eau pour
fabriquer 1 kg de
bœuf 22000 l d'eau pour faire 1 kil de
bœuf c'est complètement fou il faut plus
de 1000 l d'eau pour faire TR avocat
avocat qu'on aime tous il faut seulement
2 l d'eau environ pour faire 1 kg de
protéine d'insecte pourquoi parce que
les insectes vont chercher l'eau
directement dans le nourriture justement
on va parler de la nourriture pour faire
ce même kilo de protéine de bœf il faut
environ 12 k de nourriture contre
seulement de à nouveau pour les
insectes je
disais
alnutre
ser 18% des get de ser prod par l'humité
VI de notreimentation
agculture jusqu 99% des de gaz ser bil
conventionn on se dit il a quelque chose
à creuser là c'est pas mal et puis aussi
les insectes ils ont l'avantage d'êre
tout petits du coup on peut les élever
dans les trois dimensions donc c'est
induit qu'on peut rapprocher les usines
plus petites des villes pour éviter de
faire faire des centaines voire des
milliers de kilomètres à nos aliments
bon vous allez me dire que des avantages
ça va être easy et ben non pas tout à
fait parce que je sais pas si parmi vous
il y a déjà des personnes qui ont mangé
des insectes peut-être
oui forcément
euh en ocdent on mange plus vraiment
d'insectes on va pas se n cacher
pourtant c'est c'est pas vraiment
différent de manger un criquet qu'une
crevette je veux dire physiquement puis
on mange des trucs particulièrement
dégoûtant des huutres par exemple mais
c'est très bon voir même des escargots
et ben ouais ça a pas toujours été le
cas figurez-vous parce que l'insecte
finalement a accompagné l'homme depuis
ses tout débuts nos ancêtres
préhistoriques étai des chasseurs
cuilleurs donc c'était beaucoup plus
simple pour eux de se pencher ramasser
un petit criquet et puis le manger vous
imaginez vous attaquer un mammouth vous
avez déjà vu un mammouth c'est plutôt
balaise et puis c'est c'est dangereux
donc c'était plus simple plus récemment
no nos ancêtres les Grecs et les Romains
mangeaient aussi des insectes des
cigales des fourmis des criquets et on
retrouve les mentions de l'antomophagie
le fait de manger des insectes dans les
trois principale religion monothéiste
bon ça a pas duré au 15e siècle en
Europe on a arrêté de manger des
insectes pourquoi parce que l'insecte il
était grouillant il était sur le sol il
ravageait les cultures par conséquent il
a été banni de notre alimentation et on
a même retrouvé dans les archives euh de
de l'église des procès des des
excommunications des exomunions pardon
d'insectes c'est quand même dingue
bon au final vous dites peut-être tous
bon bah ouais on mange plus d'insectes
et c'est triste et ben en fait si vous
en mangez tous tous là vous mangez des
insectes vous mangez 500 g d'insectes
par an et par personne sans le savoir
sous forme de petits morceaux qu'on
trrouve partout dans le pain dans vos
jus de fruits vos légumes et cetera et
cetera je vous félicite et puis on va
retrouver aussi dans les colorant le
colorant E120 le rouge cochenille qui va
être utilisé par l'industrie
agroalimentaire pour pour colorer les
bonbons les boissons même la charcuterie
parfois et je vous rassure vous n'êtes
pas seul il y a à peu près 2 milliards
et demi de personnes qui mangent les
insects sur Terre 2 milliards et demi ça
fait un/ers de l'humanité quand même he
donc on en mange en Asie du Sud-Est en
Afrique sub-saharienne on en mange aussi
en Amérique latine et chapolines au
Mexique et puis on en mange aussi en en
Amérique du Sud
bon en Europe qu'en est-il et ben en
Europe ça commence commence à s'y
remettre il y a plusieurs cabinets
d'études qui ont estimé que le marché
européen de l'insecte comestible
représenterait en 2030 entre 300 et 360
millions de dollars bon c'est plutôt pas
mal puis 2030 c'est demain donc en 2012
avec Bastien rabastin mon associé on a
créé une entreprise pour remettre les
insectes dans vos assiettes on a
commencé très simplement par l'apéritif
parce que l'apéritif c'est sympa c'est
marrant généralement on n pas sol à
l'apéritif on est là pour partager donc
on a commencé par des produits à base
d'insectes entiers assaisonnés
croustillant petit criquet pouriv tomat
séché c'est c'est vraiment délicieux et
puis ensuite on a fait des barres
protéiné des pâtes aussi enrichi la
farine d'insecte pour les gens qui sont
pas prête
encore à manger des insectes entiers ça
leur fait peur et puis le futur de Jimy
ou pardon le futur de notre entreprise
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est de finalement
texturer la protéine pour pouvoir
apporter une mâche au produit pour
pouvoir on va dire apporter une solution
alternative à vos supports protéinés
aujourd'hui que vous utilisez dans votre
alimentation les steaks de soja les
steaks de viande et cetera et cetera bon
ça va prendre du temps pour info les
sushis poisson cru ça mis une quinzaine
d'années à arriver dans nos assiettes et
à se généraliser et être accepté on est
vraiment bien conscient de ça mais
encore 3 ans on vendait quelques
dizaines de kilos d'insectes par an là
l'an dernier on a passé le câ de la
tonne c'est plutôt pas mal seulement tr
4 ans et puis il y a quand même trois
points sur lesquels on va se devoir
d'insister c'est notre mission le
premier point c'est la sécurité
alimentaire les insectes sont les
cousins décrustacés et par conséquent
contiennent les mêmes allergènes par
conséquent si vous êtes allergique au
crustacé ne mangez pas d'insecte le
deuxième point c'est le prix ça fait
8000 ans qu'on élève des poulets 8000
ans qu'on a acquis une certaine
expérience en la matière ça fait que 20
ans qu'on élève des insectes donc vous
imaginez que pour l'instant les process
sont à améliorer ce qui fera baisser les
prix et puis les les économies d'échelle
de l'émergence du marché vont permettre
aussi de faire baisser ces prix là et à
ce momentl ça sera vraiment très
intéressant pour le pour le
consommateur le deuxième point sur
lequel on est vigilant le trème pardon
et ça vous concerne vous ici à Assas
c'est la réglementation alors très
souvent la réglementation évolue plus
lentement que l'innovation et le marché
mais encore une fois bonne nouvelle en
2018 avec l'arrivée l'entrée en vigueur
du nouveau règlement Noel food européen
les insectes seront pour la première
fois considéré comme une doré
alimentaire ça c'est vraiment une très
très bonne nouvelle pour
nous alors je vais conclure assez
simplement les insectes vont pas
remplacer votre steak haché de bœuf
votre steak de soja ou votre poisson
c'est pas notre objectif ok ça va venir
en complément nous prô une une une
alimentation
flexitarienne manger moins manger de
meilleure qualité plus varié de manère
ce que dans l'avenir vos sources de
protéines soient apporté par un peu
d'insectes un peu de microalgu un peu de
viande et cetera et cetera et puis je
terminer sur un chiffre assez percutant
depuis ses débuts l'homme n'a domestiqué
que 15 espèces animales pour son
alimentation 15 imaginez 2 secondes
qu'on puisse ajouter une 16e espèce les
insectes qui elle-même est considérée
enfin qui est composée de plus de 1800
espèces déjà identifiées comme
comestibles ça sera un grand pas pour
l'humanité un grand pas dans la
nutrition un grand pas dans la sécurité
alimentaire un grand pas dans
l'environnement et puis aussi sur le
plan je veux dire gustatif et
gastronomique parce que je vous rappelle
juste que le meilleur restaurant du
monde qui est situé en Danemark qui
s'appelle le Noma a des insectes à sa
carte alors j'espère que je vous ai
ouvert l'appétit j'espère que vous serez
prêt à sautez le pas avec nous et que
vous mangerez des insectes merci
beaucoup